we underestimate how much it takes to
really give a loving uh dedication to
raising a child I mean my wife really
wakes up sometimes two o'clock three
o'clock five o'clock how could she work
I knew before I got married and I was
working with fashion models in New York
for about 10 years and I got a nice
little you know small City girl like
Village girl from Germany Evangelical
Christian and her parents are nearby her
grandmother is nearby her sister's
nearby her cousins are nearby and she
gets to see this whole extended family
we've got cows and horses and stuff very
different than New York I don't know I
think I think having my wife stay at
home I think she's happy and she's a
liberal